u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
met with jordan's foreign minister ayman
safadi in washington on monday in a
pre-planned meeting
both urged de-escalation and committed
to a two-state solution
but it's imperative that all sides take
steps to
de-escalate and calm the situation and
again i'm
deeply concerned about the the rocket
attacks and even as all sides take
steps to de-escalate israel of course
has a right to defend
its uh its people and its territory for
these attacks maintaining peace and
stability in jerusalem is
key our focus right now on ensuring that
the
uh escalation stops and for that to
happen we do believe that
all illegal and provocative measures
against
either the peoples of the
sheikh jarrah or in terms of violations
into al-haram must stop
status quo needs to be preserved and the
rights of the palestinians need to be
respected
around the world protests in solidarity
with palestinians
from beirut to the uk and outside the
israeli consulate in toronto
they waived palestinian flags
pro-palestinian protests erupted in
turkey too
thousands taking to the streets to
denounce israeli aggression
seen in occupied east jerusalem over the
weekend
and in amman jordan police blocked
protesters from reaching the israeli
embassy
where demonstrators called for the
ouster of israel's ambassador
our message today is clear continue the
public pressure on the government in
order to close the embassy of the
zionist entity
and our beloved capital amman and deport
the criminal ambassador who desecrates
our capital
in washington a growing number of
democrats in congress
are pressuring biden to be more engaged
and even the u.s domestic politics are
fascinating because some key democrats
both in the senate and even more so
in the house of representatives are very
much against what the israelis are doing
and are saying so vocally so it's going
to be
a very difficult balancing act for the
buying administration
president biden had hoped to keep his
focus in the early months of his
presidency
on domestic affairs things such as the
rollout of the covet 19 vaccine
and the economy but it's becoming
increasingly clear that he now
could be facing his biggest foreign
policy crisis
of his presidency and might not be able
to keep the u.s
on the sidelines much longer gabriel
lozando
al jazeera washington
mohammed weiss is a political analyst
and researcher who specializes in the us
and middle east he joins us on skype
from washington d.c
good to have you with us so how much of
a coherent policy do you think the biden
administration has at this point and how
to tackle
the israeli-palestinian issue
it is not coherent policy that we need
to talk about
we need to talk about the lopsided
policies of all the us administrations
from 1948 until today
israel occupied palestinian land is
still
occupying and announcing palestinian
land killing palestinians
they signed a peace deal with the
palestinians in 1993
and nothing was implemented from it and
israel continued to announce palestinian
land and occupying
palestinian homes the latest was the
shaykh
situation where the israelis were trying
to replace
the palestinian residents of
by with new settlers who are coming to
take over
their homes so i mean
the u.s policy it is known very well
known
and nothing have changed since 1948 even
today
the u.s government refused to allow a
vote at the uh
the security council condemning the
israeli actions in in palestine
let me jump in here and bring you the
israeli narrative
they say that they're having to impose a
law and order situation because
palestinian protesters are throwing
stones
uh well uh what uh
now we are talking about the chicken and
the egg uh
the israeli occupation is the cause of
all evil
it is not the palestinian presence on
their own land
and trying to go to pray at the mosque
where
the israeli forces are protecting
settlers and herds of settlers who want
to come in
and desecrate the al-aqsa mosque
so yes the palestinians are protecting
their holiest
shrine and the first mosque in islam was
the al-aqsa mosque
so who is the aggressor here it is
israelis
of the official forces and the the
the protection that the israeli forces
and the israeli government gives to
these settlers criminal settlers
who learned how to take things
from the palestinians without
repercussions and without even trial
uh so i yeah the israeli narrative
is only for public consumption but the
truth and the reality of this stuff
it's very clear for all of us for the
palestinians i am a result of the
israeli occupation i'm a refugee
uh and i have been a refugee all of my
life because of the israeli occupation
all right let's come back today cannot
blame the victim
they cannot blame the victims for what
happened let's come back to the u.s
situation
a gallup poll in march of this year
found two interesting dynamics the
majority of americans continue
to sympathize more with israel than the
palestinians
but a majority of democrats for the
first time
some 53 percent now favor the us
pressuring israel more than pressuring
the palestinians
is the biden administration caught
between these two dynamics do you think
no the is the the biden administration
is caught between two dynamics
domestically in the united states the
the left and the left of left
and the extreme right wing and the
middle left the middle right
it is a struggle for who is going to
govern america
republicans and democrats palestine has
nothing to do with this
it is who wants to appeal for who
in order to make it to the white house
yes i'm not here
make belittling what bernie sanders and
the left-wing in the united states
democratic party is they are all about
human rights and civil rights but the
majority
if you put the majority which is
republican
majority plus the let's say one third to
40 percent of the democrats who stand
with israel
then it gives them an overwhelming
majority to stay
the course by i mean
ignoring the palestinian rights and
ignoring the aggression
committed by the israelis against the
palestinians
and what we heard from the secretary of
state today the first word out of his
mouth is israel have the right to
protect itself
what about the palestinians who are
under occupation who is going to protect
them they are defending themselves with
stones
the israel the israeli government is
killing palestinians with f-15s and
f-16s
and f-35s made in america okay so we
cannot equate
the the the the victim with the
with the criminal all right thank you so
much mohammed always there
thank you